talk about stormy Daniels stormy Daniels
is an adult film actress who had an
affair with Donald Trump she was paid a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
hush money to not talk about it and the
story became the center of a number of
controversies related to Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen - possible
campaign finance issues and stormy
Daniels was arrested not long ago and
the second that this arrest took place
it smelled odd to me it stunk to me and
we know now thanks to a whistleblower
that the entire thing was planned in
advance stormy Daniels was arrested in
Columbus Ohio at a strip club about two
weeks ago there were undercover vice
officers there who said we were there we
saw stormy Daniels violating an Ohio law
because she touched the club goers and
12 hours after her arrest the charges
were dismissed but of course it got a
bunch of attention it helped to further
smear and discredit stormy Daniels or at
least to attempt to do that but it all
seemed really weird from the get-go were
these officers randomly at that strip
club at the exact time that stormy
Daniels was coming through town and
performing it stunk to me like a
political smear attempt and we now have
emails from a whistleblower at the City
of Columbus which expose that Police
Detectives and vice officers were
emailing back and forth with links to
Stormies upcoming appearance pictures of
stormy Daniels with Trump videos of her
dancing and a map of where she'd be
performing and when the arrest happened
police said that stormy Daniels merely
ended up mixed up with a human
trafficking and prostitution operation
but of course if she ended up mixed up
in that why were officers sending each
other pictures and videos of stormy
Daniels because if stormy Daniels was
merely in the wrong place at the wrong
time
you wouldn't have people like detective
Shana Keckley who was one of the
arresting officers emailing herself from
her personal email to her work email
videos and pictures of stormy Daniels
and then the bombshell which is that
officer Shana Kelly was involved in
emailing herself and with
they're officers there's an email that
has been revealed at this point where
she said to another officer you're
welcome thank me in person later I got
the elements we arrested stormy this
morning and so now there is every
indication that stormy Daniels didn't
accidentally by chance get caught up in
an operation looking to weed out child
trafficking it was the opposite it was a
pre-planned arrest specifically
targeting stormy Daniels I'm not
surprised
this is what I thought it was from day
one and it turns out that it was yeah it
sounds like a hit job to me too but I
don't think it would be too effective
right because the idea is to discredit
stormy Daniels and then you can say that
maybe she didn't have an affair with
Trump maybe there was no campaign
finance violation but who in the public
really cares about this she was arrested
for essentially doing her job
well I I am not so sure because it's all
narrative and even though you and I say
well hold on a second the truth of the
hush money and the legality of the hush
money has no bearing on whether she
touched a customer in 2018 in a Columbus
Ohio strip club we get that but for the
narrative crowd this actually does
discredit stormy Daniels and that's why
I think it's so dangerous and trumpets
like let's put aside the Trump thing now
this is evidence that the Columbus
Police are straight-up lying about what
happened and of course since there is a
connection to Trump there are even more
questions that now need to be answered I
initially read that Mayor Ginther Andrew
Ginther is the mayor of Columbus Ohio
I read Ginther is furious and I thought
oh good well he's going to get this
taken care of
no Ginther is furious that people are
criticizing the police this is a
corruption scandal there are political
disagreements that we can have like
what's the optimal tax rate for fairness
or for economic growth this is
corruption and cronyism whether it links
back to Trump or not it shouldn't be
partisan it shouldn't be political
whether it's Anthony Weiner or Donald
Trump or the Columbus police or whoever
this is corruption plain and simple and
if it is what it appears to be it should
be career-ending for the officers that
were involved in this fiasco but because
the mayor is angry with the people
rather than with the police
as usual there may be no consequences
whatsoever yeah and the mayor isn't
upset with the corruption he's upset
that the cover-up got out apparently
nobody telling no thinking person can
doubt that this was politically
motivated as I said within hours of the
arrest but now we have days of
premeditated proven premeditation and
then back to the original reason for the
arrest remember the original arrests
happened because stormy touched
customers we've now learned from
Columbus Police Department chief Kim
Jacobs that cops screwed up the arrest
because the law prohibits performers
from touching patrons
only if they are dancers who perform
regularly at the club stormy Daniels was
a guest performer so she never even
should have been arrested in the first
place according to the law
congratulations to everybody involved
another complete and total comedy of
errors discuss this with us on our
reddit discussion forum if you're
interested ww david pakman.com slash
read it re d di t today's program
sponsored in part by Blink is comm slash
Pakman I've talked about blinkers before
it's this awesome app that I've been
using for several months now and what it
does is take the best and most
critically acclaimed non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to in one
sitting you could listen to ten books in
an afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go
to be li NK is t.com /pa k ma n